jetzt bin ich Ecke geflogen wo ist
Debitor hin m warte hier guck mal ich
bin hier oben bei dem hochhausp
Debitor geht das of course hey cool aber
da ist jemand ach doch nee h h das B
ich GLB der ist hier irgendwo nee doch
nicht ich geh mal hier hoch ich will
jetzt mal irg ein Hochhaus nach ganz
oben warte ich gehe jetzt in irgendein
Hochhaus oder ich TP mich zu schuffel
ja hey GU mal der wieder am
Spa ja und was macht er hier ich habe
keine Ahnung der hat jetzt ein Bogen ja
ich gucke in der Gegend rum aber ichb
ach der warade glaub ich am crafting
table hat sich da seine Dingens gemacht
seine Suppe das kann gut sein irritieren
ich weiß nicht ob ich immer noch blind
bin also nicht
se sit mich eigentlich ich glaube nicht
ich hoffe mal nicht obwohl er guckt mich
so dum an oder guckt dich
[Musik]
an der fühlt sich voll verarscht oder so
schr ist Schwein aber ich glaub dürfen
töten die Schweine oder wir sind ja
schon im SPECT
bekommen guck mich
an guck
[Musik]
mal damit da kann er sich was färben
cool oh
Gott wo ist Spark jetzt hier
oh alle sind
hier wenn Du uns sehen kann was denkt er
sich ja meine Fans weiter wir laufen
noch so ein paar Spacken um mich rum
keine Ahnung was S machen das wä voll
geil wenn so ein multiplay Server sein
würde wenn der so geil aufgebaut ist so
richtig verlassen irgendwie das ist voll
cool GU mal die ganze Zeit
umeguckt doch er sieht dich ne ja hast
du nicht wenish gemacht nein ich habe
das gerade wieder ausgemacht a
so gut dann kann kann ich eigentlich vor
ihm stehen bleiben um ihn anzuhalten ne
oh wo geht er jetzt hin
das the game das mal irritieren warte
wir könnten uns doch wir können es doch
theoretisch Sachen cheaten und die dem
geben aber das wäre blöd ne das fällt
auf
so welche sind wir nicht warte mal ich
muss Blume hinwerfen das darf man woh
aber man darf hier den Dingens anmachen
ne den Counter ne den das darf man
natürlich ist eine Kiste
ah das war da drin ey das ist bestimmt
voll doof wenn wir seine Sachen
aufnehmen oder so ja ich werde F sich
voll verarscht bleib ein bisschen hinter
dem ich bin ja Wenisch ne jetzt bleibt
da stehen jetzt schreibt oh auf ihr
Spacken wer ist noch am
Leben bin
tot wer ist noch am Leben ich
nicht nur noch drei scheiß was kaputt
gemacht nein
nein
Alter
gemacht was hast du gemacht einmal
linksick einmal links dann war schon
kaputt wie ja ach du bist Creative
Mode sp und TT sind noch am Leben he
guck mal da ob ist schffel wer
kann de W
Weg
gleich hallo ach siehst du mich
überhaupt wenn ich wen bin ich sehe dich
ja
okay oh Junge soll wir hier bleiben geh
nicht so schnell soll dies ein Raum da
reingen W ver od soll gemin
verrecken
das what the
F wäft hin
Alter ich kein Plan wo er richtig hin
will läuft einfach überall durch ich se
hier niemand ich lauf mal ein bisschen
im Kreis ne jetzt gich kein Essen mehr
ich glaub der will einfach V uns davon
egal hinterher ja wir s immer noch hier
t Tom alles weg
hier war doch mein
Wald
Alter du brst die ganze Zeit Regel du
mach das kaputt denk du bist das weil
ich nicht se sehen zu sehen
bin liegt der Reichtum und was macht sch
geht hin geh Reichtum re ich will sein
ich wer das TNT und der macht den Tot
oder so ich bin vorhin da ja nimm alles
raus ne ich er muss das er
gucken ne das war ich nicht das war
nicht
das wo war der denn jetzt Alter SP der
olle Camper ja e CERs
[Musik]
Spark
ich z do mal hier rein
so jung was für ein Camper SPK Alter was
ist denn das
für ich war nach einer Minute
tot ja ich hab war die ganze Zeit bei
dir hast du es gesehen ja ja n gar nicht
B gar nicht aufgefallen guck mal ich la
so los und hab es total verpasst dass
man sich Items nehmen konnte ich das
habe ich auch verpas bin einach
weggerann dann W ich habe ich jetzt hier
40 Minuten nichts aufgenommen wenn man
so will hab zwischendurch war richtig
stolz wenn ich meine Kiste gefunden habe
Alter das war so
langweilig irgendwo warst du mal bei
einer bei so einer Mechanismus wo du ein
Knopf gedrückt hast dann ging so eine
Tür auf und hast du noch mal gedrückt
aber dann bist du wieder weggegangen
wenn du reingegangen wärst wärst du
gestorben ab bin ich gestorben fast
gestorben halbes Herz so ja ich habe ich
habe blo gesehen weil du kannst da ja
nicht hoch du kannst ja nicht die Türe
hoch ja dann hinter drin ist halt noch
ein Knopf und dann fällt man ganz weit
runter bin ich jetzt eigentlich im
Creative Modus ich kann ja immer noch
machen was ich will ja ich binvival ja
gameeme gameeme kannst jetzt machen B
jetzt P ach so okay e Tom nimmst du noch
auf ja geh mal spectate Spark phix ich
weiß muss erstm oxytion eingeben wie
geht das W
wenn
so du musst mal bei shuffel bei Spark
reingucken alter das ist der einzige der
sich am Anfang wirklich die Sachen
genommen hat ich ich habe das gar nicht
gewusst dass da noch welche übrig waren
überhaupt welche sind jetzt habe ich
Sachen eingesammelt g immer wieder
erneuert immer Nacht oder so keiner
schafft das gegen den der hat bisher
alle getötet wie er kämt da
oben für ein ich bin wenigstens
rumgerannt ich bin rumt dann bin ich 20
Minuten nach 20 Minuten oder so bin ich
Hal zum Startpunkt zurückgekehrt Alter
was hat denn der der hat ein
verzaubertes Schwert der hat ein
goldschwert der hat ein Eisenschwert ja
klar ja klar der einzige der sich am
Anfang Sachen genommen hat bei mir war
so ich bin losgelaufen hab mir geholt
bin weggelaufen aufal war ich am Bren
war ich tot und dann dachte ich so komm
eine Minute brechen mal die Aufnahme ab
ich keinen Bock mehr und jetzt nehme ich
irgendwie wieder auf ich weiß nicht
warum deswegen ist es bei mir jetzt auch
gerade ein bisschen komisch mit den 15
Minuten Parts ich muss dann den ersten
Part irgendwie nur 11 Minuten lang
machen weil ich ja 4 Minuten später
angfangen komm ich wieder raus aus
seiner blöden Sicht spectate off ach so
zusammengeschrieben das ist doch
irgendwie behind vor allem die die
Lungen alle am spaw rum ich habe mich
irgendwie erst durch die halbe Welt
bewegt da war kein Mensch in der Nähe ey
so langweilig war das ich habe mich dann
gefreut wenn mal irgendwie mal ein paar
Pilze umlen kann ich mal gucken was ich
verpasst
[Musik]
habe ich fand voll unfair dass direkt am
Spawn so übelst geile Sachen sind weil
wenn einer allein dieses verzauberte
Schwert bekommen hat weil er schon quasi
unbesiegbar und Tom Tom Spark hat auch
noch so ein goldenen ne der alles
möliche der hat doch das komplette
Inventar noch voll mit irgendwelchen
eisenschwertern und so boah gegen den
jetzt keiner geschafft der hat jetzt
auch glaube ich alle bisher getötet ich
hatte ich hatte ein Bogen und und vier
Pfeile und du hatast drei porkchop und
drei Leder und und Leder ja stimmt
Lederstiefel hatte ich noch Wahnsinn ey
mm hät mich am liebsten direkt gegenüber
gestellt V der dann noch mit seinem
Behinderten Apfel dann ey das wäre gar
nichts geworden mm
mm mhm eigentlich die BR comfy jetzt
auch noch da ja aber ir habe ich da
keinen Bock reinzugehen weil da sind da
20 Leute oder so die die ganze Zeit
dazwischen quatschen ja das stimmt auch
wieder okay jetzt kann ich eigentlich
meine komischen Komis Sichtfeld wieder
normal
Stellen ich gucke jetzt bei dem
tableetis Gamer zu die müssen sich doch
mal irgendwann begegnen so da ist jemand
ach nee das ist der ist beim
[Musik]
dr Ken ist wieder was wo ist den der ich
geh jetzt einfach rein ich will ja dass
das nochmal gestartet
wird vor allem Ding wieso wieso macht
man die Kisten am Anfang ey die hätte
man
Verm aber sowas von die jetzt einfach
vermehrt über die ganzen über die ganze
Strecke hier verteilen können die ganzen
Häuser und so weiter und hätte jeder
irgendwann was gefunden ja das F ich
auch besser aber so da ist halt SPK war
von Anfang an der mit den meisten Sachen
hat darum die anderen getötet deren
Sachen bekommen immer so weiter und wer
nichts hatte kommen und vor allem ich
habe mir nachher ein paar andere Kisten
angeguckt ein paar Gebäuden ne das
höchste was da drin war war vielleicht
mal ein Pfeil oder ein pork chop oder
sowas damit hast du kein kein keine
Chance gegen Spark oder so ich habe dann
e crafting table gesucht Ich war ich war
übelst am suchen ja du wollst eine Suppe
machen ne ne ich wollte mir Pfeile
machen da waren BL da waren die
Bestandteile der Pfeile drinne und ich
habe die ganze Zeit eine crafting table
gesucht aber ich kann mir auch keine
selber
machen so also an die Zuschauer die
jetzt immer noch da bin was ich glaube
ich mal stärkstens bezweifle das hier
ist jetzt die schöne Map die wir
gespielt haben ultra spannend war
es nimmst nimmst du wirklich noch auf mm
Gott ich weiß nicht ob das sich
irgendein Arsch noch anguckt
ey das ist mir scheißegal
ey bei mir war das auch so blöd ne am
Anfang ich habe total vergessen Fraps zu
starten dann auf einmal ging's los und
dann war ich direkt tot dachte ich mir
okay sollst jetzt überhaupt anfangen
aufzunehmen habe ich mir das einfach so
gesagt ja okay aber geh das ist echt
total doof jetzt auch gewesen dass wir
das nicht alle so hochladen können wie
wir das wollen weil ich meine in Amerika
bei anthonem und Captain sparkles war so
en hat sofort Z Stunden hochgeladen
Captain sparkles und 15 Minuten Parts
mein Gott ist jetzt auch nicht so
schlimm oh was ist das für ein
Alter was ist denn das für ein Teil Spar
Phoenix und table tennis Gamer die
Schlacht
beginnt klar wer gewinnt Zombie was er
ist tot
Alter gefät das gefällt mir ich sammel
gleich alle Items ein wieso ist hier
hier ist ein Zombie in der Luft was soll
das denn ja das ist was ist das für ein
Viech hier da nimmt Zeug
wieder h er hat jetzt gewonnen
ne hat das denn geschafft SPK zu töten
ja was hat ein goldschwert der hat ein
goldschwert Quatsch diamantschwert
Mensch was ist denn das für ein vie ey
das ist do behindert warum spaw da
solche riesen Zombie teile ich find es
irgendwie lustig das ist ein riesen
Zombie ich denk die ganze Zeit ich
dachte die ganze Zeit der schäbt in der
Luft direkt vor mir bis ich und und und
der hat jetzt gerade mal drei experience
gekriegt e dafür gibt 100 experience für
so ein vie muss man Creeper spaw muss
man so ein Creeper von der Größe und
dann ich finde das jetzt irgendwie
gerade ein bisschen doof hier was ist
jetzt los hat jetzt gewonnen kriegt
jetzt irgendwas ich glaube nee warte wer
wer ist noch da ist nicht nur noch der
nur noch table tennis Gamer ach so mE
nicht
cool das war's quasi jetzt ich habe
jetzt dreiviertel Stunde aufgenommen
spektakulär ja ich habe jetzt 49 Minuten
auch
[Musik]
insgesamt mal
reinziehen uns mal sagt wie er das
gemacht hat ja ja ich glaub der ist in
dieser massenkonf warte ich versu mal n
mal wen wieder sowas ist da gucke ich
mir die Map von vorne bis hinten ich w
das auch gemacht ich zie den rein eben
jetzt hier los aber ich glaub der ist
auch was soll das den jetzt voll die
voll die
springkatzen
what
F
Katzen Creeper
cats
Alter ja wow anstatt D jetzt irgende
Blumen runtergeregnet kommen ja komm
explodierende
Katzen wen schon ja die sind ja richtig
sauer dann Kitt bringt gar
NS
so okay ich glaube jetzt passiert
passiert eigentlich nichts mehr egal ich
mache jetzt einfach mal den Schluss für
meine Aufnahme so Leute das war jetzt
eigentlich Hunger Games la nicht spannt
wie nie das war jetzt Hunger Games 2 war
natürlich sehr spannend also ich kann
euch nur empfehlen geht den kinoilm da
werdet ihr deutlich mehr zu lachen und
zu feiern haben als hier und ja ich
wollte mich noch mal dafür entschuldigen
dass ich direkt am Anfang so übelst
verreckt bin weil das war halt auch
einfach so Spark war der einzige der der
sich dieses Sachen quasi geschnappt hat
und dann hatten wir die anderen gar
keine Chance na ja das kann ich bezeugen
bestätigen heiß das Tom ja oder bezeugen
ich habe es ja selbst mitbekommen du war
g vergammelten häus unten ist ja geil
ist ein Bahnhof ja
das auch kistenun sollen bin ewig längst
gelaufen keine Kiste B echt lang
gelaufen se gar
nichts na gut ich ma Mal tschüss für
meine Aufnahme tchü no ir boah
toll